a simple reality is our borders are safe
and secure you know these individuals
the members of the Armed Forces have
come to help out when the strikes are on
are carrying out a very straightforward
function and of course backed up by
computer systems and scans that are not
allow us to identify people of worry
coming into the country
so we can see there is a cue that
you that our armed forces are simply
more efficient than border force staff
well first of all you know if you came
10 minutes later there were no cues at
all this is because two flights have
arrived at the same time I've been here
for over an hour and seen uh cues
rapidly decrease I think it's pretty
efficient especially here in Terminal 2
at Manchester which is a brand new
facility effectively no I I think what
it demonstrates is the armed forces are
managing to substitute for striking
workers on the point of entry into the
UK they're using that technology I said
to make sure that it is run efficiently
and cleanly through the system and
passengers are getting the service that
they expect from Manchester Airport and
I think overall we're not seeing any
disruption here to people's travel I
think that's a good thing and I think it
also shows that ultimately the
government's responsibilities to secure
the Border but also to make sure people
can come back come and go about their
business unhindered
should the UK be introducing travel
restrictions on people flying in from
China following the announcement from
the US last night what I think the
government has said it's not going to
keep that under review and review
whether different countries with covert
outbreaks Etc should should obviously
face uh different restrictions I think
as we as we speak that is being reviewed
and I'll expect to see some
clarification I think by the Department
of Transport probably today or tomorrow
indeed the decision we've seen in the
last hour or so that India will now be
covered testing from several countries
from Asia if that is the decision that
we aren't going to be doing so how can
we be sure that isn't going to put too
much pressure on an already overloaded
NHS well I think first and foremost
that's a matter certainly the Department
of Transport to work out the balance
between the medical advice that it
receives and indeed the the flow of
traffic but you know there are hundreds
of countries who are not seeking County
to do that and I think it's very
important at this time of year what we
do is we make sure that those countries
that don't have covid can travel freely
to the United Kingdom and vice versa
there are thousands of British tourists
right now who will be flying back to the
UK and then of course making sure we
target whatever restrictions we do where
there are places of Greater concern not
just with covid we do that already with
other medical conditions uh that if that
if pandemics break somewhere else then
of course those are powers we have but
at the moment I think we keep it under
review we look at the traffic and where
people are coming from into this country
and then no doubt the Department of
Transport will make their views known
I'm just going to ask you a couple of
questions about Ukraine now if that's
okay Minister UK has reported more than
120 missiles being fired from Russia
from the air and sea targeting key
infrastructure should Britain be doing
more to help
well first of all Britain is at the
Forefront of of its effort to help we
put in only recently thousands of
anti-air missiles to help bring down
these Iranian drones that Russia is now
firing rather indiscriminately both a
critical infrastructure and indeed
civilian areas and we'll continue to use
our know-how our training and indeed any
hardware support we can in 2023 to make
sure that Ukraine can defend itself and
I think it's important to note that the
targeting of Civilian National
infrastructure and indeed civilian areas
is against Geneva conventions Russia is
breaking international law in what it's
doing not only with its Invasion but
also with the targeting is carrying out
and there will be a response from the
rest of the world to that type of
behavior
in cash terms how much has the UK's Aid
to the Ukraine cost so far well last
year of 2.3 billion and from Financial
year 2023 it'll be we'll put in another
2.3 billion that some of that is
non-military Aid some of that is you
know the likes of humanitarian supports
such as generators some of that is
obviously military hardware some of it
is training we train 10 000 we trained
ukrainians in the UK and we'll train
another 20 000 in the UK and some of it
is effectively backfilling British stock
so stocks we've given away we need to
replace to make sure our armed forces
are up to date and on the Forefront of
being able to defend ourselves so that's
what makes up the 2.3 billion we're
committed to another 2.3 billion for
2023 because it's vital for all of us
and all our security that Russia fails
and its Ambitions in Ukraine a strong
message is sent around the world that
you know breaking international law and
brutality and torture and rape is not
acceptable to this house community and
we'll deal with it together